[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans 100 % Sénat quelles sont les causes
et les origines profondes des violences
urbaines qui ont suivi la mort du jeune
Naël l'été dernier c'est ce que tente de
déterminer une commission d'enquête au
Sénat pour cela elle a auditionné quatre
sociologues sentiment de marginalisation
manque de mixité sociale finalement les
causes très similaires aux émeutes qui
ont touché la France en 2005 avec
parfois un certain opportunisme je vous
propose de suivre leurs propos merci de
votre présence physique bien évidemment
ah et qu'est-ce que j'ai vu c'est
Monsieur dub que j'aperçois c'est ça
voilà très bien merci de de de votre
présence ce matin je suis accompagné de
plusieurs collègues peut-être que vous
ne les voyez pas mais madameage brigot
madame Nar et Monsieur Vogel qui sont
des commissaires aux lois des membres de
la commission des lois et qui suivent
bien sûr la mission d'information qui
sont mis en place sur les émeutes qui
sont survenus le 24 juin dernier enfin
du 24 juin au début du mois de juillet
mais bien que nous débuté à l'heure la
commission des lois ce matin les
collègues ont été passionnés par les
texes c'est moi qui dit ça il a dé ça
devient
dramatique et donc dans le travail que
nous menons dont l'objectif est d'avoir
un rapport mois de février ça c'est une
chose c'est essayer de comprendre qui
s'est passé et à travers j'allais dire
tous les sujets c'està-dire que bien
évidemment que la commission des lois
s'intéresse au problèm juridique premier
sécurité très bien mais pas seulement on
veut essayer de d'avoir une
approche multifactoriel et en tous les
cas une connaissance assez précise de ce
qui s'est passé pour potentiellement
proposer une évolution législative je
dis bien potentiellement ou un certain
nombre de recommandations qui pe être de
nature réglementaire c'estàdire qui
dépend du gouvernement mais en tous les
cas ne pas passer à travers ou ne pas
éviter quelconque sujet voilà donc je
vais vous laisser la parole très
rapidement maintenant je sais pas si
vous avz prévu un ordre entre vous ou
pas du tout au quel cas je vais
peut-être donner la parole à Monsieur
jardin vous êtes d'accord bon ben voilà
entendu merci
[Musique]
beaucoup
alors mon travail c'est d'être ingénieur
de recherche CNRS donc je travaille
beaucoup sur de l'analyse de données et
ça fait maintenant une quinzaine
d'années que je travaille sur la
question des quartiers marginalisés et
des phénomènes politique qui s'y déroule
et également des enjeux relatifs aux
formes de violence politique et enjeux
de sécurité
euh j'ai eu l'occasion finalement de
d'essayer de lire un peu tout ce qui
avait été écrit depuis une quinzaine
d'années sur ce sujet des marginalités
urbaines en France et ailleurs
et ce qui m'a paraît extrêmement
extrêmement frappant à la suite des
événements de l'été
2023 c'est le sentiment finalement de
nouveauté qui anima beaucoup de
réflexions avec l'idée que les
phénomènes qu'on a qualifié d'émeutes ou
de violen urbaines auxquels on a été
exposé ont été présenté comme quelque
chose qui sortait de la trame habituelle
de l'ordinaire de la connaissance qu'on
pouvait déjà avoir des enjeux de de
révolte de protestation de violence dans
les quartiers marginalisés et euh ce
phénomène de nouveauté si je me fais
expression n'est pas nouveau puisque en
2005 on avait déjà présenté les émeutes
de 2005 comme des émeutes d'un genre
nouveau euh qui contrastaent avec celle
des années 70 ou des années 80 et puis
là il y a l'idée Queen 2023 on a de
nouveau une nouveauté qui se surajoute
euh au fait des és de 2005 h au cours
des 10 dernières années j'ai été
toujours très surpris de voir combien la
mémoire de 2005 finalement était passé
quelque chose euh d'historique quelque
chose qui était plus un sujet
d'actualité qui appartenait au passé et
qui était finalement une question un
petit peu réglée et euh une difficulté
qui était passagère qui qui nétait plus
au prisme des priorités politiques ou
des enjeux qui méritaient une attention
particulière et finalement ce qu'on voit
dans le courant de l'été c'est que bien
on remet sur le devant de la scène une
préoccupation pour la situation des
quartiers marginalisés au prisme de ces
violences donc le premier constat que je
ferais euh c'est que finalement euh
cette question de la violence et de la
protestation violente elle donne une
existence politique au quartiers
marginalisés puisque en l'absence de ces
violences les quartiers marginalisés
n'ont pas véritablement euh de poids
dans les enjeux politiques dans les
débats nationaux dans la définition des
politiques publiques ou dans la
réflexion des questions générales qui
peuvent traverser la société en matière
scolaire en matière de logement en
matière de transport et cetera et
finalement la violence elle fait exister
c'est quartiers et leurs habitants dans
le champ politique d'une façon négative
d'une façon qui est souvent perçue comme
Stig stigmatisante ou dévalorisante
d'une façon qui est souvent mal vécue
par beaucoup d'habitants mais très
certainement l'existance de cette
commission l'existance d'un certain
nombre de commandes qui peuvent être
adressées à mes collègues universitaires
ou chercheurs montre bien que il y a un
intérêt quand il y a la violence et
quand l'absence de violence moins
d'intérêt pour ce qui se passe dans ces
quartiers ce qui apparaî également c'est
le caractère pluriel de ces phénomènes
puisque on a qualifié comme un ensemble
homogène les émeutes de l'été 2023
il semble davantage qu'on ait une
stratification de différents phénomènes
des phénomènes de réaction immédiate
dans les hautes scènes aux environs de
Nanterre
après la mort du jeune Naël et puis une
diffusion dans d'autres territoires avec
d'autres modalités d'action par la suite
qui a été interprété comme étant
participant du même mouvement mais en
fait avec des différences de nature de
pratique des différences de répertoire
d'action de mots d'ordre ou voire
parfois d'ABS sens de mot d'ordre euh
qui viennent questionner finalement
l'unité du phénomène vraisemblable que
les personnes qui se sont affrontées
avec les forces de l'ordre dans les
quartiers marginalisés ont des grilles
de lecture des profils sociologiques des
motivations un peu différentes de celles
qui se sont rendues dans les
centres-villees pour voler des pertes de
basket en cassant des vitrines et donc
le terme desmeutes à minima recouvre une
diversité de situation et de
configuration qu'il est difficile de
bien documenter parce que on n'a pas de
cartte très précise de quel type
d'événement il y a eu dans les
différents territoires donc on a un
petit peu de difficulté quelques mois
après les événements à à pouvoir couvrir
hein C ces différen de nature de
l'émeute un troisème enjeu qui me paraît
essentiel c'est la question de la
dynamique durable de marginalisation de
certains quartiers euh c'est quelque
chose qui est frappant quand on fait
l'historique de la politique de la ville
sur une quarantaine d'années c'est
combien le constat deux tentatives euh
renouvelées et revendiqué à chaque fois
comme ambitieuses euh et suivie d' d'un
constat d'échec ou en tout cas de de
succès très limité euh par rapport à une
logique de marginalisation qui se
prolonge dans le temps dans beaucoup
d'espaces qui semble être une dynamique
difficile à enrayer et qui n'est pas
pour autant la dynamique d'ensemble des
grandes métropoles puisqu'on voit qu'il
y a pas du tout une dualisation entre
des quartiers aisés des quartiers
pauvres mais une majorité de quartiers
qui sont plutôt des quartiers
intermédiaires et mélangés et localement
dans des configurations très spécifiques
des quartiers qui sont pas
particulièrement marginalisé et qui le
reste durablement et si on prend des
dispositifs qui ont 20 ans d'âge il
concernent encore la plupart de ces
territoire
aujourd'hui je pense que un des enjeux
importants c'est de déspécialiser le
regard sur la banlieue il y a eu l'idée
très fort je pense après 2005 selon
lequel seul certains quartiers ciblés
par des dispositifs particuliers petique
publ étai les territoires et les lieux
où résidaient les personnes qui
concentraient le plus de difficult ulté
ce qui est le cas quand on quand on
objective avec des critères
sociologiques mais on voit bien que
finalement c'est un enjeu qui est un
enjeu national qui concerne des
territoires au-delà des quartiers les
plus
marginalisés et qui du point de vue de
ses répercussions de ses conséquences
raisonnent à l'échelle du pays et pas
seulement à l'échelle des banlieux donc
je crois pas qu'il y a une crise des
banlieux en tant que telle il y a des
difficultés dans les banlieux qui
provoquent une crise à l'échelle
nationale de la structure des
institutions des politiques publiques et
de la structure du tissu social en tout
cas des structures de relations sociales
euh qui sont qui sont présentes donc euh
je pense qu'on peut pas regarder
l'insécurité ou la ségrégation dans les
quartiers marginalisés sans la regarder
en même temps dans des espaces qui sont
également plus aisés parce que c'est un
processus qui est dialectique et qui
finalement s'alimente euh de façon de
façon
réciproque dans ce processus général un
élément qui me semble mériter
l'attention c'est que lorsque vous
parlez avec des responsables des forces
de l'ordre des services de sécurité vous
vous indique la préoccupation d'une
montée de la violence en France une
montée de la violence qu'on retrouve pas
ou peu dans la plupart des indicateurs
qui s'agisse des statistiques
administratives ou des enquêtes de
victimation mais néanmoins une violence
qui est plus présente dans les conflits
sociaux et on peut présenter des
exemples comme les mouvements
écologistes ou les mouvements autour des
conflits du travail mouvement des
retraites mais on peut penser également
mouvement des gilets jaunes on a eu une
succession de mouvements sociaux dans
lesquels la violence était finalement à
un moment ou un autre une facette du
rapport politique en l'absence d'autres
relais d'autres médiations
institutionnelles je crois que la
question des banlieux est une question
paroxistique de cette dynamique en
l'absence quasi complète de relais
politique structuré finalement il n'y a
soit pas de confrontation soit une
confrontation qui passe par la forme de
la violence et qui est un des enjeux à
construire et qui pas forcément
seulement du travail des institutions
mais c'est de réussir à trouver des
canaux de désaccord et d'affrontement
politique qui ne passent pas par la
violence et euh qui permettent de faire
émerger des enjeux de façon beaucoup
plus structurelle que ces affrontements
sporadiques qui arrivent voilà à
échéance régulière et en causant
beaucoup de dégâts et et beaucoup de
dommage aussi pour les auteurs pour
certains très jeunes dont la trajectoire
sociale scolaire familiale va être
fortement impactée par leur
participation et leur condamnation dans
ces
contextes peut-être pour pour en
terminer avant de de passer la parole à
mes collègues euh je crois qu'il y a un
enjeu également très important euh sur
la réflexion avec euh les forces de
l'ordre et la relation à la police euh
il y a eu le sentiment peut-être de
mettre en cause euh uniquement les
responsabilités individuelle des agents
de police euh ce qui est effectivement
une partie importante puisqu'ils ont la
détention moyens de répression et que
leur usage dépend de de leur exercice
personnel mais qu'il y a sans doute
aussi des questions de doctrine sur les
modalités et la présence euh des forces
de sécurité dans certain nombre de
quartiers et c'est spectaculaire quand
on regarde sur une vingtaine d'années ce
débat sur les modalité précise
d'existence la police de proximité puis
sa suppression puis son retour et on
voit bien qu'on est finalement dans une
oscillation des dispositifs euh sans
lign directrices vraiment structurelles
sur le long terme je crois que un des
grands enjeux si on veut voir un
développement euh de ces quartiers
marginalisés et les voir réduire l'écart
avec le reste de la société française 16
c'est sans doute dans le besoin d'ancrer
sur le long terme un certain nombre de
dispositifs et de ne pas avoir ces
fluctuations euh qui sont souvent
souvent peu productives un dernier mot
peut-être sur des territoires qui sont
très très peu évoqués mais qui me
paraissent mériter une attention
particulière au regard des indicateurs
socio-démographiques qu'il présentent ce
sont les territoires ultramarins dans
lesquels il y a des formes de
marginalités qui sont très très intenses
euh mais qui passent souvent un peu au
second plan euh des enjeux des
dispositifs de politique publique
également parce que ce sont des
territoires qu'on a moins bien documenté
que ce soit dans les données de
recensement ou dans les données d'enquê
de victimation depuis les dernières
années donc il y a une volonté de mieux
prendre en compte ces territoires mais
je crois que c'est un enjeu important
qui passe un peu trop souvent au second
plan merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
jardin monsieur merk je vois plus nos
interlocuteurs en visio c'est normal ils
ont disparu allez-y monsieur mer
merci monsieur le
[Musique]
Président
alors dans
la l'invitation que je remercie la
convocation à venir aujourd'hui parmi
vous c'est une invitation
merci je vous en remercie quand même
et on
m'a précisément demander de de
d'intervenir autour des des équipements
publics et des équipements
culturels qui ont été pris par cible
lors des manifestations et qui et à
propos desquelles j'ai enquêté pendant
très longtemps alors je vais essayer de
donner un certain nombre d'éléments
permettant de de construire une certaine
intelligibilité parce que les attaques à
ces
équipements provoque souvent une une
perplexité que ce soit
de la part des des personnels des des
bibliothèques par exemple ou des
élus des instances ministérielles et
puis de de l'opinion publique en
général le ce que je vais présenter et
trouve sa source dans un
travail de terrain de longue haleine des
de nombreuses enquêtes qui se succèdent
et donc une temporalité qui est qui est
nécessaire et qui est précise ce
pourquoi aussi si euh d'une certaine
façon de mon pour ce que je peux faire
les émeutes du mois de juin sont encore
faiblement connu on les on en connaît
très peu
de du point de vue des enquêtes que je
peux mener
euh il y a quand même un certain nombre
d'éléments on on a évoqué à l'instant
cette question de la nouveauté et de la
et et la
continuité de ce type de de
manifestation et la la la focale doit
être large
et considérer l'ensemble des acteurs qui
sont qui sont engagés dans dans le
conflit ou dans la conflictualité que le
meut met en
scène l'une des choses qui est qui est
qui est une nouveauté qui est évidente
ne se trouve nulement dans les quartiers
mais ailleurs on vient de de d'exprimer
le caractère politique
dans l'intelligibilité dans la
compréhension de ce type de phénomène en
2005 on en on disait exactement le
contraire qu'il y avait un déficit de
socialisation politique que c'était des
actes nilistes que c'était des actes à
l'extérieur de la citoyenneté que tout
ça s'expliquait comme une forme de
pousser des sentiments de broncas de de
de
de de manque de de rationalité et
aujourd'hui on est passé euh
heureusement je crois à une analyse
complètement différente qui qui qui
donne à voir ces manifestations comme
des mouvements sociaux comme des
manifestations sociales comme des formes
de mobilisation qui donnent une forme de
la politique une un changement dans la
la l'expérience de la citoyenneté et de
notre vie démocratique qu'elle soit à
caractère négative ou positif c'est pas
c'est pas pas c'est pas au sociologue
peut-être de le de le de le qualifier
d'une d'une manière ou de l'autre j'ai
essayé
de de faire de cette question une
question centrale des mes objets de
recherche j'ai proposé pour cela
un notion qui est celle de la politicité
populaire qui essaye de de rendre compte
du fait que l'expérience de la
citoyenneté n'est pas la même selon les
groupes sociaux ça paraît une évidence
mais il faut le rappeler à chaque fois
et cette expérience à voir avec le type
de conflit dans lequel chaque
groupe prend part d'une part
et et donc elle se distingue
de par exemple la citoy l'expérience de
la citoyenneté des classes moyennes mais
aussi d'autres segments des classes
populaires et c'est l'un des éléments
sur lequel je vais revenir à l'instant
et deuxièmement le fait que cette
expérience de la citoyenneté ou cette
politici évolue dans le temps
et pour
saisir ce qui se passe dans les
quartiers
populaires il faut avoir une attention
particulière à la relation ou au rapport
des habitants et du groupe c'est pas
pareil le groupe que les personnes ou
les familles avec les institutions parce
que il y a une spécificité
euh française pas exclusivement
française mais pour des gens qui
travaill aussi ou qui enquête dans
d'autres horizons quand on fait quand on
mène une démarche comparative euh dans
d'aut dans des sociétés à caractère plus
libéral ou dans des sociétés plus
pauvres comm comme celle d'Amérique du
Nord par exemple ou dans des sociétés
plus pauvres où où l'État a un caractère
segment
ire
uncertain la la où l'État social est
moins fréquemment pressent ce qui
caractérise un quartier populaire c'est
l'absence de
l'État en France ce qui caractérise la
vie des habitants des quartiers
populaires c'est l'omniprésence de
l'État il faut s'interroger très
précisément pour la à propos de la
manière dont ces familles etes et ces
personnes trouvent solution à la plupart
de problème qui concerne la vie
quotidienne qui est laaleure l'éducation
la santé le logementement la culture le
sport les
transports euh tout cela et plus est
entre les mains d'institutions publiques
et cette expérience de la vie
quotidienne c'est-à-dire le fait que les
problèmes ne trouvent pas leur solution
ni par la solidarité locale ni ni dans
le marché en payant avec son salaire des
services par exemple ou en accédant à
des biens avec son salaire fait que il y
a une conflictualité qui est directement
politique la vie quotidienne de ces
personnes est directement politisée
parce que ils sont en conflit récurrent
et quotidien avec un fonctionnaire un
agent représentant de l'institution qui
prend des décisions et qui est un
fonctionnaire un membre de la fonction
publique derrière lequel se trouvent les
autorités les élus le personnel
politique et donc il y a une
politisation
immédiate de la conflictualité sociale
et ça c'est une note majeure
euh une coordonnée principale euh à
l'intérieur de laquelle se trouvent les
équipements culturels
2è et je vais y revenir plus précisément
mais deuxième élément sur lequel je
voudis attirer l'attention c'est sur ce
qu'on pourrait appeler l'historicité de
l'émeut l'historicité est double d'une
part et ça a été
rappelé c'est une histoire qui commence
disons en 1979 ou au début des des
années des années 80 et où on observe de
de cette relative unité des classes
populaires en France au autour de la
classe ouverrière le détachement d'un
segment d'une partie qui se manifeste
par l'émergence d'un nouveau répertoire
de l'action collective pour pour ce qui
relève de notre jargon de de ceux qui
faisons de la sociologie politique
c'est-à-dire les gens commencent à agir
collectivement autrement que par le
passé ce n'est plus la manifestation le
vote et la grève qui sont les modes
d'expression naturels ou primordiaux de
ces de ces groupes à travers les
syndicats et les partis politiques qui
assurent l'intégration et la
socialisation politique c'est donc les
meutes le monde associatif qui a été
suscité et euh créé suite à la réponse
de l'État à ces émeutes les lois de
décentralisation et la création de la
politique de la ville qui fait exister
une myiade d'associations dans tout le
territoire et un militantisme très
important quand on interroge aujourd'hui
les membres qui ont 40 50 ans de ces
associations qui sont indispensables à
la vie démocratique et bien on
s'aperçoit que beaucoup parmi eux
étaient des émetiers par exemple il y a
20 ans parce que ça dure depuis 40
ans et cette cette cette historicité est
est très importante cette dimension de
l'historicité est très très importante
mais il y en a une autre dimension de
l'historicité qui est celle de
l'événement et la la manière dont on
découpe l'événement dont on euh la
manière comment qu'on va employer pour
circonscrire l'événement est très
importante est-ce que ça commence avec
la mort d'un jeune dans le dans un
conflit avec la police dans l'immense
majorité des cas suivi d'une émeute et
suivi d'une inscription dans l'espace
public qui est
primordiale l'émeut a un caractère
éminemment symbolique ce n'est pas
l'instauration d'une d'un rapport de
force qu'on cherche mais la possibilité
d'inscrire dans l'espace politique local
ou national en fonction des des
circonstances euh un événement
c'est-à-dire de susciter la prise de
parole
c'est ça ça c'est le noyau de
l'historicité et il y a un moment en
aval et un moment en amont de
l'événement en aval c'est une
conflictualité sourde silencieuse et
cachée que justement les mîes cherchent
à faire venir dans l'espace public et il
y en a une autre en amant ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui fait partie de
l'événement heureusement fait intervenir
d'autres acteurs la presse les sciences
sociales les autorités qui vont se
prononcer qui vont prendre la parole qui
vont qualifier les faits qui vont
qualifier les protagonistes et qui vont
de ce fait donner son caractère
politique l'inscrire dans la dans la vie
du système politique l'une des clés
d'interprétation de l'émeut c'est la
coupure qu'il y a entre les espaces de
paroles à l'extérieur de l'institution
et à l'extérieur de l'espace du système
politique et ce qui peut venir à
l'intérieur par exemple les incendies de
bibliothèques que j'ai étudié en 2005 je
trouve 70 incendies des bibliothèques
depuis les années 80 il y a jamais eu un
article de presse là-dessus jamais une
prise de parole jamais un débat
politique concernant l'incendie d'une
bibliothèque on aurait pu penser que
dans un pays comme la France la mise à
feu d'une bibliothèque aurait pu
susciter une grande émotion ça n'a pas
été le cas aujourd'hui il y a des
articles dans la presse la télévision
s'y intéresse je suis ici pour en parler
il y a un changement ça c'est le moment
qui suit les meut
pour finir et dire à mon des
bibliothèques et et des équipements
culturels les bibliothèques donc au
sintègre font partie de ce de cet
appareil institutionnel qui fait les
quartiers qui les produit du logement
jusqu'à la bibliothèque en passant par
les terrains des sports les écoles et
cetera et de ce fait le bibliothécaire
fait partie d'une chaîne d'agents qui se
trouve face aux habitants comme étant
euh une association du même une
association du même qui va qui qui donne
son même caractère à l'instituteur au
bibliothécaire à l'agent de la fice HLM
de la PMI et le policier et donc il y a
de ce fait une face à un face- à-face
qui se produit entre des agents et des
habitants qui sont eux deux mis par
l'État et par la situation sociale au
cœur d'une conflictualité qui trouve
souvent ses causes ailleurs donc il
n'est pas il n'est absolument pas
étonnant que le conflit se prenne les
institutions comme cible de la
manifestation même lorsque c'est un
policier qui se trouve à l'origine ou en
conflit avec la police et qu'on va
brûler une bibliothèque quand on regarde
les choses de ce point de vue-là on voit
que la bibliothèque ce n'est plus une
bibliothèque populaire qui trouve son
origine dans une émergence dans les
habitants qui s'organisent pour créer un
espace de réflexion pour créer un lieu
d'émancipation mais une implantation du
service public qui vient là pour aider
les habitants individuellement mais qui
a énormément de mal à parler au groupe à
participer du groupe d'où la question
récurrente est-ce leur bibliothèque ou
notre bibliothèque c'est ça la question
que se posent les habitants et la pierre
GTA vient interroger l'institution pour
lui dire alors tu es notre institution
ou laaleure l'écrit de ce point de vue
se pose dans l'espace d'une sacralité
oou c'est le sacré de l'autre qu'on va
essayer de busculer parce que c'est
l'écrit le terrain de l'école du marché
du travail qui nous est scamoté la
parole de la vie politique de la vie
institutionnel et c'est tout cela qui
est mise en question à travers la pierre
et le feu en essayant de rendre visible
cette problématique qui a du mal à être
dite les habitants eux-mêmes les
émeetiers eux-mêmes ont énormément de
mal à pouvoir transformer cette action
symbolique en une action une action
textuelle discoursive avec une parole
permettant de la rendre intelligible par
elle-même c'est à nous de le faire voilà
merci de votre attention merci beaucoup
monsieur alors je me retourne vers euh
euh nos intervenants qui sont en vision
monsieur Domingo et Monsieur Dubet y
a-t-il une préférence pour intervenir ou
d'autorité euh et bien écoutez je le
premier de ma liste c'est Monsieur
Domingo alors vous avez la
parole bonjour merci pour pour votre
invitation donc moi je vous parle depuis
depuis la province et depuis une ville
qui est la ville de Toulouse
euh qui a subi là aussi depuis une
vingtaine d'années euh B ces phénomènes
que l'on qualifie d'émeutes ou de
violences urbaines notamment en
1998 à la
suite de la mort d'un dénommé Pipo donc
un jeune qui est mort là aussi dans une
dans une altercation avec la police et
qui a donné lieu à à des émeutes sur la
ville qui a enclenché d'ailleurs par la
suite la mise en place d'un d'un
dispositif qui était émergent à l'époque
qui était celui des contrats locaux de
sécurité donc l'idée qu'il fallait
traiter de manière
partenariale pas seulement policière
d'ailleurs c enjeux ces enjeux de
quartier euh avec finalement l'émeut qui
va donner naissance à un effet à une
mobilisation de dispositifs publics
essayant de voilà de
renforcer l'action publique sur ces
quartiers qui sont à à Toulouse et les
quartiers notamment d' du grandmail et
qui en effet comme d'autres dans la
région parisienne ou en provinces sont
parfois affectés par par ces phénomènes
euh alors je vais essayer de sans trop
répéter ce qu'ont dit mes collègues mais
c'est vrai souligner l'historicité de de
de ce phénomène ditmetier ou de
violenceces urbaines qui alterne entre
des des fortes continuités mais aussi
des des formes d'innovation et de
nouveauté euh les continuités euh
elle s'inscrivent en effet dans dans une
histoire qui a qui a au moins une
quarantaine d'années en tout cas si on
prend le le début de la réflexion sur
sur la question des quartiers avec
l'émergence de la politique de la ville
donc depuis le début des des années 80
François Dubé je pense pourra y revenir
parce qu'il a il a a travaillé ça depuis
de très nombreuses années mais donc on
est dans une forme de de grande
continuité avec des événements notamment
en 2006 une forme de récurrence de ces
événements qui en font finalement
désormais non plus des événements
exceptionnels mais des événements qui se
reproduisent selon une forme de
régularité plus ou moins importante et
qui se rappelle à nous dans ce qui est
finalement la question sociale de ces
quartiers euh ces ces émeutes ces
violences urbaines elles résultent
souvent d'ailleurs de d'un événement
déclencheur souvent lié à une
altercation entre la police et des
jeunes avec parfois la
mort la mort d'un jeune qui va générer
en tout cas
l'étincelle qui va mettre le feu au
poudre et créer une forme de
déstabilisation plus collective du
quartier et puis ensuite du une forme de
diffusion sur le territoire national
donc là aussi on a parmi les continuités
on l'a vu finalement il y a un certain
nombre de quartiers qui qui restent des
des quartiers dissensible malgré ces 40
ans de politique de la ville avec là
aussi une population celle des jeunes
issus de ces quartiers qui sont des
quartiers paupérisés des jeunes qui font
l'expérience plus ou moins conscientisé
d'ailleurs plus ou moins politique de
certaines formes d'inégalité de
marginalisation sociale et d'une
expérience qui est à la fois objective
mais aussi subjective je pense qu'il
faut réintégrer la la dimension
subjective les perceptions sociales que
peuvent avoir certains jeunes de leur de
leur positions sociale des inégalités
qu'ils subissent les enjeux de
reconnaissance euh donc des des jeunes
qui se
sentent marginalisés victimes
d'inégalité alors parfois souvent à
raison hein mais aussi parfois avec des
formes de distorsion peut-être de
représentation qu'il qu'il possède et
qui les font euh se sentir exclus euh
d'un système auquel il pensent ne pas
appartenir et donc ce qui questionne
directement ce ce lien de citoyenneté ce
lien civique euh que l'on invoque
souvent mais qu'on a du mal à à inscrire
dans une forme de matérialité et de
subjectivité plus
quotidienne la l'autre élément l'autre
continuité c'est l'attaque contre les
équipements les incendies de véhicules
les affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre le la destruction ça a été dit
des écoles des bibliothèques des
équipements publics qui représentent
l'état autre continuité c'est celle de
la en tout cas de la logique de
diffusion sur le territoire national qui
fait que l'émeut c'est à la fois un
phénomène local mais c'est aussi un
phénomène national et un phénomène
partagé alors parmi finalement les les
nouveautés à mon avis qui sont celles
des émeutes de de
2023 c'est d'abord
la la rapidité de la contagion de de ce
CES émeuts et
puis la rapidité de
leur de leur fin
puisque elles ont duré finalement assez
assez peu de temps donc on est sur une
forme d'embrasement très fort et avec
une forte mobilisation d'ailleurs de
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre et une
réponse judiciaire qui a été très très
rapide également qui nous montre à la
fois je pense un un phénomène qui euh
qui lui aussi donc qui tient la la qui
tient aussi à la volatilité peut-être du
mouvement euh qui est finalement moins
organisé je pense qu'on ne le dit euh
parce qu'il est le résultat de de la
coalition de petits groupes de jeunes
qui sont là aussi parfois par
opportunisme euh avec une parfois
peut-être une charge politique qui est
beaucoup plus faible que précédemment on
parle de la question de la mobilisation
du mouvement social bon je pense que
cette question du mouvement social elle
est elle est toujours là hein en
filigrane mais peut-être par rapport aux
nouvell génération de ces jeunes qui
s'engagent dans ces dans ces dynamiques
là euh on a une population peut-être
aussi beaucoup plus diversifié avec des
agendas beaucoup plus hétérogènes
euh on a aussi sûrement une une présence
en tout cas ressentie plus forte des
violences à la fois du côté des ametiers
mais aussi du côté de la réponse de la
réponse policière en tout cas la
perception de la violence elle est
beaucoup plus forte elle est aussi mise
en scène dans les médias de manière
beaucoup plus explicite et donc sans
doute ressenti beaucoup plus euh
beaucoup plus fortement au niveau des
subjectivités à la fois des forces de
l'ordre et des et des jeunes euh avec
quelques quand même événements qui
peuvent questionner moi ce qui
m'a quand même alerté c'est l'attaque
par exemple de la prison de freine par
des groupes donc on est je pense que
dans les précédentes émeutes on avait
pas constaté l'attaque d'une prison
l'attaque directe contre certains élus
donc des signes qui montrent un effet
des alors il sont des signes émergents
peut-être pas donc sur lesquels il faut
je pense être vigilant et qui questionne
ce rapport à la violence et et la
confrontation directe là cette fois-ci
avec les les représentants de l'État
euh finalement une des notes une des
nouveautés aussi c'est la la la question
du pillage euh on a vu dans cette
dernière séquence d'meut
que finalement lesmeut constitu aussi un
espace d'action pour pour aller piller
des des supermarchés des centres-villees
des magasins donc dans une logique et
finalement alors qu'on peut qualifier de
politique hein mais qui est aussi
finalement plus peut-être pour certains
acteurs moins formalisés selon ce mode
et qui relève du fait que l'on se
profite de l'meut pour se servir
euh et pour bénéficier finalement du de
ce que de ce qu'offre la société
capitaliste dans une logique qui est qui
est tout à fait
instrumentale autre élément aussi qui me
paraît assez nouveau ou en tout cas qui
se renforce c'est la question de la
médiatisation euh via les réseaux
sociaux euh qui n'existait pas de
manière aussi forte et aussi aussi
importante à l'époque et qui permet aux
jeunes finalement de produire leur
propres images de l'émeut et donc je
pense qu'on a pas encore très bien
compris comment tout ça fonctionne donné
à la fois dans euh la diffusion de
l'émeut dans le partage d'expérience
réciproque chez chez ces jeunes dans
l'émulation qui peut en résulter et dans
la spectacularisation de de l'émeut voir
dans la jouissance tout simplement euh
de ce partage de ce partage d'une
expérience collective au niveau local
mais aussi au niveau national
euh donc je reviendrai sur ce qui a été
aussi dit finalement c'est que ces
émeutes de 2023 elles sont peut-être
plus composites qu'on le dit euh elles
ont une dimension pour certains acteurs
sans doute jeunes qui qui qui qui qui
peut renvoyer une lecture politique hein
la la mort du jeune Naël en effet un
erre renvoie un questionnement sur le
rapport aux institutions à la police ça
c'est je pense qu' un élément important
mais dans sa diffusion je pense que le
mouvement devient aussi de plus en plus
hétérogène il devient parfois des
fouloirs euh espace de confrontation et
parfois pour certains acteurs peut-être
plus organisés comme certains
trafiquants de drogue c'est une manière
de mettre en difficulté euh les
autorités publiques euh auxquels elles
sont confrontées euh au fil du au fil
des
jours deux points encore peut-être je
sais pas s'il me reste un petit peu de
temps euh je pense que ce qui est
important c'est d'abord de repenser
peut-être dans le le volet solution
quelque chose qui est souvent mis de
côté c'est ce lien entre la jeunesse des
quartiers populaire et la police donc on
tourne beaucoup autour du débat mais on
on a peu de de de solutions assez direct
qui remettrait en effet qui renvoerait
une doctrine précise de prévention du
rôle préventif de la police dans dans
ces quartiers euh et ça cette doctrine
là elle est souvent renvoyée d'ailleurs
aux acteurs sociaux en disant la police
fait son travail les acteurs sociaux
doivent et donc on est dans une forme de
de répartition des rôes qui à mon avis
est pas forcément toujours bonne parce
qu'elle renvoie à du coup une forme de
conflictualisation entre ces jeunes et
la police et avec l'enjeu aujourd'hui à
mon avis qui qui qui est sous-estimé du
rôle des polices municipales qui se sont
beaucoup structuré au cours des
dernières années et qu'on doit
aujourd'hui faire rentrer dans
l'équation et qui ces polices
municipales souvent qui miment sont dans
une forme de mim me institutionnel sur
le plan culturel et et des modes
d'action avec avec la police nationale
et donc là aussi je pense qu'il faut
repenser le rôle des polices locales en
lien avec celui de la gendarmerie ou des
poli de la police nationale sur la
manière dont se crée ce ce rapport
police population ce qui renvoie des
enjeux de formation des policiers
nationaux de la gendarmerie nationale
mais aussi des polices municipales et
comme cela a été dit aussi sur les
enjeux les les médiations que l'on peut
organiser entre ces deux entre les
jeunes et la police alors sachant qu'il
y a quand même des expériences qui sont
qui existent hein comme les
correspondants police population les
centres de loisirs jeunes gérés par la
police nationale mais voilà qu'il
faudrait sans doute approfondir et pour
pour pouvoir avoir une lecture plus
préventive de de l'activité policière
qui soit pas seulement lorsqu'il y a des
émeutes centrés sur les enjeux de
maintien de l'ordre le le second point
ce qu'il faut qu'on arrive à mieux
comprendre les nouvelles subjectivités
juvéniles he le leur transformation les
politicisations ordinaires qui existent
chez ces chez c'est jeunes et peut-être
on s'est beaucoup euh je pense centré
sur les publics adolescents et puis sur
les plus jeunes je pense qu'il faut on
voit que dans ces émeutes on a beaucoup
de de 18 euh de 18 25 ans donc les les
jeunes adultes et euh cette catégorie
des des jeunes adultes on les on les
aborde souvent en effet par le biais de
l'intégration socio-économique et c'est
un point important mais il faut aussi
peut-être les les reprendre le reprendre
le débat à partir de leurs besoins
politiques et des canaux d'expression
politiqu qui peuvent exister euh qu'on
peut mettre à leur disposition et là je
pense qu'on est un peu en déficite avec
des enjeux aussi intergénérationnels euh
comme ça a été ditin ces jeunes
aujourd'hui sont parfois les enfants des
Meutiers et donc avec des transmissions
intergénérationnelles dans les familles
qu' peut-être qu'on peine à avec des
choses qui qui ont été transmis et qu'on
peine à à comprendre aujourd'hui le
dernier point à mon avis qui qui est
important c'est de travailler sur les
mécanismes de prévention du phénomène
euh on a une politique de la ville qui
se relance on a une politique national
de prévention délincrance qui va se
relancer en 2024 donc c'est comment on
fait comment on intègre ces enjeux de la
prévention ou des émeut ou de la du
débriefing des émeutes et quel type de
dispositif préventif on peut intégrer
dans ces politiques publiques là et on
se rend compte que la question émeutière
elle est jamais prise en compte par ces
politiques de prévention de la
délinquance euh quand on reprend les
différents textes depuis une vingtaine
d'années qui essaent de de cadrer ses
objectifs de prévention de la délincance
la question hmetière elle est pas
présente en tout cas pas directement et
dans la politique de la ville finalement
la politique de la viille est plus vue
plutôt comme une sorte de correctif
sociale qui permettrait de de prévenir
de nouveaux mouvements on voit bien que
tout ça reste malgré tout
difficile et pour produire des effets
donc ce qui renvoie aussi à des enjeux
d'évaluation pas seulement national mais
aussi local et d'animation de la manière
dont on anime et on met en œuvre ces
dispositifs locals avec sans doute des
enjeux de débureaucratisation de cette
politique de la ville et de ces
dispositifs qui sont très nombreux et
qui rendent finalement les choses assez
lisibles
illisibles pard don en terme de contrat
social donc il y a peut-être un travail
sur la manière dont l'état finalement
principalement est en lien avec les
collectivités local définit ses
politiques et les animes voilà je je
pense quep beaucoup merci Monsieur
Domingo merci beaucoup on va donner la
parole à Monsieur François Dubet alors
c'est pareil est-ce que je le
vois je ne le vois
plus je ne sais pas moi je vous je vous
vois je vous je vous entends bien
parfait ben écoutez Monsieur Vous AVEZ
LA
PAROLE bien alors comme ça a déjà été
évoqué j'ai j'ai le triste privilège de
l'âge c'est-à-dire d'avoir étudié les
émeutes du début des années
80 et je je crois qu'il faut d'abord un
peu comprendre que c'est à la fois des
révoltes quant à leur signification et
des émeutes par leur mode d'action après
tout une révolte contre des injustices
vécues pourrait donner lieu à des man
manifestation des grèves autre chose que
des émeutes mais le vocabulaire lui-même
nous met dans dans une sorte
d'incertitude alors moi ce qui me frappe
c'est c'est quand même la répétition je
veux dire que c'est la répétition sur le
sentiment de discrimination d'injustice
de chômage de mise à l'écart et cetera
bon il y a ce sont des choses
extrêmement connues c'est le
déclenchement quasi automatique ou quasi
régulier par une confrontation avec avec
la police c'est la disparition des
acteurs locaux c'est très spectaculaire
et ça date depuis les années 80
c'est-à-dire que le maire disparaî le le
les travailleurs sociaux disparaissent
les enseignants disparaissent il n'y a
plus rien euh c'est un vide politique
qui qui qui s'installe c'est la
répression c'est le retour au calme
c'est les réactions politique assez
convenu les uns disent c'est d'abord une
révolte les autres donc c'est un
problème de justice sociale les autres
disent c'est d'abord un problème de
maintien de l'ordre donc un problème de
police et je partage ce qui a été dit
c'està-dire qu'on a été plus habile pour
faire des politiques de la ville que
pour réformer l'action policière je
ferme cette parenthèse depuis une
quarantaine d'années alors évidemment
chaque fois qu'il y a des émeutes on
explique que c'est pas comme la dernière
fois mais c'est en réalité assez assez
proche ce qui a changé a déjà été
souligné c'est-à-dire que par la grâce
des réseaux sociaux il y a un phénomène
traîné de poudre qui est extrêmement
spectaculaire dans la dernière émeute on
a vu des villes toute petite dans
lesquelles on nimaginait pas qu'il y
aurait des émeutes dans lesquels les
jeunes sont entrés dans des sortes de
jeux de concurrence avec d'autres parce
que tout ça était sur la toile
euh je crois que la grande
caractéristique c'est au fond que la
seule émeute qui a créé un mouvement ça
a été on en fait aujourd'hui le 20e
anniversaire ça a été la marche pour
l'égalité contre le racisme parce qu'il
y avait des acteurs locaux parce qu'il y
avait des travailleurs sociaux parce
qu'il y avait un curé parce qu'il y
avait une oreille politique alors le
destin de cette marche est une autre
affaire mais en tout cas on était dans
une logique démocratique au fond où une
révolte se transformait en mouvement
social en
revendication ce qui me paraît
caractéristique évidemment et au fond le
plus tragique c'est c'est que ce cet
embrayage qui passe du sentiment
d'injustice et de révolte à l'action
organisée politique revendicative qui
est quand même au cœur des mécanismes
démocratiques la démocratie ça consiste
à transformer des révoltes en
revendication donc à passfier la vie
sociale là c'est quelque chose qui de
toute évidence patine depuis depuis des
années et je crois même que c'est de
pire en pire parce qu'au fond ces
émeutes sont de plus en plus le prétexte
ex a des interprétations exogènes c'est
l'immigration c'est l'envahissement
c'est le capitalisme c'est le
néocapitalisme et au fond personne
n'écoute les gens c'est ça qui me frappe
et personne au fond ça a déjà été dit ne
on nentend jamais les habitants de ces
quartiers qui sont des problèmes sociaux
qui ne sont pas des acteurs sociaux donc
je crois que ce qu'il y a de de plus
pénible au fond c'est la répétition de
ce genre de d'affaire au fond son son
extension alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé je crois que la France a été dans
une situation paradoxale depuis une
trentaine d'années il y a eu des
politiques de la ville qui n'ont pas
été inefficace qui ça n'a pas été rien
je veux dire que dans ma bonne ville de
Bordeaux j'ai vu des quartiers se
transformé être plus vivable plus on a
créé des trames des bus on a mis des
équipes enfit ça n'est pas et ça ça a
beaucoup frappé j'y reviendrai les les
journalistes étrangers que qui m'ont qui
m'ont interrogé é es très surpris par la
alors je vais employer avec tous les
tous les guillemets du monde mais par la
qualité du bâti d'un certain nombre de
banlieu qui s'enflamment et qui qui
disent je comprends on ne comprend pas
vraiment pourquoi dans ces endroits qui
sont au fond qui sont plus du tout des
grands tis urbains on a des révoltes je
crois que ce qui a ce qui a été la
faiblesse de ces politiques c'est que
ces politiques là n'ont pas
affecté un mécanisme que je crois on
peut définir de la manière suivante
c'est qu'au fond dans ces
quartiers tous ceux qui s'en sortent et
beaucoup s'en sortent de ces quartiers
s'en vont les fuit il y a une mobilité
sociale et cette mobilité sociale joue
contre le quartier au fond euh j'y
reviendrai quand on quand on regarde ce
qui était les banlieux populaires les
grands ensembles les banlieux
rouges qui ont existé jusqu'au début des
années 80 il y avait des classes
moyennes les enseignants vivaient là les
travailleurs sociaux vivaient là les
jeunes ménages en mobilité vivait là
alors évidemment il y avait de la
distance sociale entre les habitants
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle la mixité il
y avait il y avait il y avait des
travailleurs bien installés des classes
moyennes et cetera aujourd'hui le
mécanisme de peuplement des quartiers
est un mécanisme qui fait que tous ceux
qui s'en sortent s'en vont et sont
remplacés par des gens de plus en plus
pauvres et qui viennent de plus en plus
loin et donc vous avez une sorte de
paradoxe entre une action sur le cadre
qui est loin d'être insignifiante et une
incapacité de de de d'agir sur un
peuplement qui fait que ça s'ppauvrit et
que c'est de plus en plus un monde
éloigné immigré étranger bon euh ça
c'est évidemment un mécanisme qui
accentue considérablement le sentiment
de
de de marginalisation
d'exclusion puisque la mobilité des uns
euh de la mobilité des uns découle
l'enfermement des autres ENF vous avez
mê comme ça il y a un mot en France
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à utiliser qui
est le mot
euh alors il est évident que si on
compare les quartiers français au grand
getto du sud de du sud de Chicago et
cetera c'est pas comparable mais quand
même si les quartiers ne sont pas des
ghettos il y a des mécanismes de ghetto
dans le quartier c'est-à-dire que ça
c'est ce qui me frappe sur
l'observation des quartiers que j'ai
bien connu et que dans lesquels je
continue d'aller c'est que ces quartiers
se sontent enfermés ces quartiers ont
été enfermés ou exclus on pourrait dire
par les politiques de peuplement enfin
pas par les politiques par les mécanisme
de peuplement de plus en plus pauvre de
plus en
plus il suffit de regarder d'ailleurs
l'évolution des indices de position
sociale des collège pour voir que
l'écart se creuse avec le le reste de de
la ville et on sait tous quand on est
sociologue et c'est très désagréable que
quand le gethetto est fortement
constitué du dehors
par l'exclusion les stigmate la mise à
l'écart et cetera il finit par se
construire du dedans et il y a quand
même beaucoup de travaux qui montrent
que le ghetto devient au fond une forme
de vie collective où on est entre soi où
on contrôle al il y a beaucoup
d'enquêtes qui ont été faites là-dessus
on finit par contrôler l'espace par
contrôler les filles par contrôler par
se surveiller par faire que le jeu des
réputations vous enferme et donc d'une
certaine manière euh le quartier est à
la fois ce qui vous exclut mais en même
temps ce qui peut en tout cas chez les
jeunes vous donner une identité par des
mécanismes de
renversement de
fierté voilà et d'ailleurs quand le
gethto est extrêmement constitué je on
peut observer que le le développement
des trafics euh procède du ghetto et et
et le et
je dirais et l'organise alors il s'agit
pas de donner dans la littérature des
romans noirs des
romans disons dans les films de scoris
on en est peut-être pas là mais des élus
marseillais me faisaient remarquer que
dans les quartiers les plus ségrégués de
la ville il y avait pas d'émeut parce
que la logique du trafic fait qu'on
souhaite pas vraiment qu' a des émeutes
donc d'une certaine manière vous avez
un un renfermement et et au fond moi
j'ai qui beaucoup étudié le système
scolaire il y a un moment où vous êtes
victime de l'échec scolaire et un moment
où au fond l'échec scolaire devient
votre identité contre
l'école ça ça a été très très bien
étudié je le signale aux États-Unis dans
des comparaisons qui ont été faite il y
a assez longtemps entre les migrants
volontaires c'està-dire les gens qui
venaient aux États-Unis pour y vivre et
pour s'y installer et dont les enfants
réussissaient assez bien à l'école alors
qu'il venaient de très loin alors que
les minorités involontaires
c'est-à-dire les les les Afro-Américains
installés là depuis longtemps
stigmatisés enfermé avait des résultats
scolaires plus faibles parce qu'il ne
croyaient pas à l'école et parce que
l'école ne croyait pas qu'il pourrait y
réussir donc d'une certaine manière vous
avez des des des des des des il faut
regarder ça je crois un peu en face des
moments où le quartier finit par
s'enfermer sur sur lui-même en tout cas
pas tous les habitants du quartier bien
évidemment mais dans une large
mesure dans une large mesesure les
jeunes et moi qui je suis beaucoup
intéressé au problèm scolaires on le
voit très bien à l'école vous
avez aujourd'hui y compris dans ces
quartier des mécanismes de fuite de
l'école du quartier du collège du
quartier par ceux qui le peuvent o les
gens vous disent je suis déjà enfermé
dans le quartier je ne souhaite pas être
enfermé dans le collège du quartier donc
je vais aller à côté et donc je vais
fabriquer le ghetto d'une certaine
manière dont je suis victime enfin je je
crois qu'il faut bien comprendre la
force de ces mécanismes parce que il
sera pas facile de les de les de
les de les contrer mais chacun d'entre
nous connaît une ville dans laquelle il
y a au moins un ou deux quartiers il
s'agit pas forcément une très grande
ville qui est complètement dans cette
logique d'auto d'exclusion radicale et
d'auto enfermement en tout cas des
jeunes euh des jeunes du
quartier ça je crois que c'est le le le
grand problème que nous avons c'est
qu'au fond nos politiques urbaines n'ont
pas
euh on pas peser sur le peuplement des
euh des des quartiers et la mobilité
sociale que nous désirons tous joue
plutôt contre ces quartiers dans
lesquels j'y reviendrai vous ne trouvez
plus
d'enseignants qui y vivent de
travailleurs sociaux qui y vivent de
militants qui y vivent tous ces tous ces
acteurs qui étaient les vecteurs d'une
transformation de la révolte en
revendication qui avait une capacité
politique ont disparu dans beaucoup dans
d'endroit où je suis allé les gens vous
disent c'est le collège des
Français parce que les enseignants sont
français de leur point de vue eux aussi
le sont ne ne vivent pas dans le
quartier ne sont pas là et d'une
certaine manière en dépit de leur
enthousiasme et de leur bonne volonté
ils sont perçus par les jeunes comme des
acteurs extérieurs ça a été dit tout à
l'heure très bien sur les incendies de
bibliothèque c'est plus notre
bibliothèque c'est
celle qu'on nous a imposé d'une certain
d'une certaine
façon je me suis beaucoup intéressé
enfin je me suis demandé pourquoi la
France avait des émeutes et que beaucoup
de nos pays voisins n'en avaient pas or
quand on regarde le les indicateurs
généraux d'inégalité sociale et
d'inégalité urbaine un grand nombre de
pays qui nous entourent ont des
inégalités sociales plutôt plus fortes
que les nôtres et des inégalités
urbaines qui ne sont pas tellement plus
faibles or il y a pas vraiment des
meutes et ça quand il aux derniers émeut
de juillet de cette année beaucoup de
journalistes américains anglais allemand
poser la question mais pourquoi chez
vous il y a ce phénomène qui ne se qui
qui au fond que l'on ignore même si
évidemment on a des des violences
juvéniles des bagarres des de la
délinquence des trafic et cetera mais la
révolte et les meutes n'existe pas alors
je me suis intéressé à à une comparaison
de la France et de l'Allemagne
alors pourquoi il y a une grande
communauté turque en Allemagne qui est
marinalisé qui est exclu qui est victime
de racisme et cetera euh et pourquoi il
y a pas d'émeut là et pourquoi nous en
avons chez nous alors la réponse à cette
question est est quand même un peu
troublante c'est c'est que au fond chez
nous en France euh les gens qui vivent
dans ces quartiers qui sont souvent des
gens immigrés enfant immigrés depuis
plusieurs générations mais toujours vu
comme des
immigrés sont en réalité assez fortement
assimilés à l'identité et la culture
française au fond l'héritage colonial
c'est que ils doivent devenir des
Français comme les autres ce qui est
très bien l'héritage colonial moins
sympathique c'est qu'ils héritent d'un
vieux de vieilles tradition raciste
aussi bon mais en tout cas ils sont
beaucoup plus assimilés par l'école par
les politiques publiques ce sont des
gens qui de qui qui seront des Français
comme les autres à un moment donné et en
même temps ce sont des ces groupes là
sont beaucoup plus exclus
économiquement que les autres si on
regarde le cas de l'Allemagne je ne je
voudrais bien me faire comprendre je ne
souhaite pas que nous devenions allemand
pour autant mais il va de soi que les
turc en Allemagne sont beaucoup plus
intégrés économiquement que ne le sont
les immigrés français par un système de
formation scolaire duel qui
est très centré sur les entreprises et
cetera et en même temps que ça reste une
communauté turque très largement
auto-organisée très large ement tourn
vers la Turquie que personne n'imagine
qu'ils deviendront des allemands comme
les autres d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas le
droit de vote et pouront pas devenir et
eux-mêmes ne souhaitent pas pour la
plupart d'entre eux devenir allemand
donc vous avez d'un côté une société qui
assimile culturellement et qui
exclut socialement ça serait plutôt nous
et ça rend fou d'une certaine façon et
vous avez de l'autre côté une société
parce que ces traditions national
entre nous pas toujours sympathique font
que on n'envisage pas
d'assimiler les communautés turques
alors qu'on va tout faire pour assimiler
des Allemands qui viennent du
Caucase qui sont mais qui sont
ethniquement vu comme les Allemands mais
qui sont économiquement qui ont une
place qui était au fond celle qu'avait
les travailleurs immigrés dans la France
de la société industrielle ils étaient
maltraités mais ils avaient une place
dans les grandes usines et cetera donc
je crois que nous sommes dans ce par
paradoxe aujourd'hui et que la crise des
banlieux de mon point de vue est à la
fois une crise sociale mais ce que j'ai
dit est d'une grande banalité mais
fondamentalement c'est une crise
démocratique je répète quand on regarde
l'histoire des l'istoire des démocraties
c'est la capacité de transformer des
émeutes en revendication c'est la
capacité de transformer des classes
dangereuse en classe saborieuse c'est la
capacité de faire entrer dans un système
des gens qui n'y sont pas or je crois
que cette capacité là elle est
aujourd'hui extrêmement faible ça a déjà
été dit de 1000 manières mais je crois
qu'elle est faible parce que les
quartiers se sont tellement fermés sur
eux-mêm que ni les
acteurs je dirais de l'État les
enseignants les travailleurs sociaux les
militants de ne vivent dans ces
quartiers ils y travaillent ils n'en
sont plus et donc ils sont perçus comme
venant du dehors que les les gens de ces
quartiers qui réussissent et qui
rentrent dans ces professions eux aussi
quitent les quartiers donc d'une
certaine manière il y a plus de vecteur
moi je me souviens avoir fait des
entretiens avec des enseignants me
disant moi je veux pas vivre là pour un
tas de raisons mais en particulier parce
que j'ai pas envie de rencontrer les
parents d'élèves sur le marché alors
que la tradition c'est que j'aV j'allais
bien finir par les rencontrer sur le
marché voilà donc je crois que là ce
sont des choses qui sont creusées
l'école ne tient pas ses promesses et
donc elle est l'objet d'un ressentiment
considérable puisque au fond l'école
française ne cesse de dire aux élèves tu
n'as qu'une manière de t'en sortir c'est
l'école et comme tu n'es pas bon tu t'en
sortira pas et on voit se développer pas
simplement de l'échec scolaire ce qui
est un problème aujour aujourd'hui avec
les les les données PISA mais on voit se
développer du refus scolaire de du rejet
de l'école puisque d'une certaine
manière on sauve sa dignité en euh
l'chouant à l'école les habitants des
quartier qu'on a vu pendant les émeutes
le disent très nettement ils disent nous
sommes l'objet de politique publique
nous ne sommes jamais les acteurs des
politiques publiques c'est-à-dire que ce
sont des choses extrêmement simples ils
vous disent on a construit tel
équipement
on n'a jamais demandé on nous a jamais
demandé notre avis on a mis en place
test dispositif nous n'avons jamais eu à
dire notre mot sur ce dispositif donc
d'une certaine manière euh
euh on fabrique des communautés exclu
mais la parole de ces communautés on
peut pas l'entendre parce qu'elle est
communautaire je veux dire que je vais
dire les choses de manière brutale si
vous mettez dans le même quartier des
gens pauvres qui croi C à la même
religion et qui s'identifie à cette
religion pour sauver leur dignité que
vous leur disiez vous ne pouvez pas
parler au nom de cette religion parce
qu'elle brise l'universalisme
républicain d'abord vous fabriquez du
radicalisme et vous les rendez fous bon
euh les Allemands avec les Turcs ont pas
ce problème puisque les Turcs
s'intéressent à la Turquie et ont des
problèmes religieux liés à la Turquie
plus plus qu'à l'Allemagne mais vous
vous comprenez bien qu'on ne pourra pas
à mon avis l'enjeu essentiel aujourd'hui
c'est de refabriquer alors c'est ça fait
très langue de bois mais un minimum de
mixité sociale dans ces quartiers ça ça
me paraît tout à fait essentiel de
trouver des voies de mobilité sociale
qui font que les gens reste dans le
quartier et ne fuit
pas dès qu'ils sont sortis de du ghetto
et je crois que c'est notre capacité
politique qui est qui est
interrogée
à travers ces
émeutes je crois évidemment mais ça
c'est un autre débat que il faudra bien
un jour redéfinir les formes
d'intervention de la police dont les
policiers et les jeunes sont les uns et
les autres des victimes il y a quand
même une singularité française dans la
gestion de l'ordre public qui devrait
nous interroger c'est en tout cas là
aussi ce que montrre les
comparaison
internationale je vous remercie merci
pardon deux collègues sont présents avec
moi y y a-t-il des
questions madame narassen alors vous
avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président merci
à vous quatre vraiment pour pour vos vos
apports vos vos réflexions vos analyses
qui sont je crois quand même assez
largement
convergente je je m'interrogais alors je
sais pas
plus directement à qui il faut poser la
question justement parce que c'est quand
même assez assez convergent il y a il y
a une
euh tout de même une une petite
contradiction dans le sens où
euh il y a une question qui se pose
enfin il y par rapport à ce qu'on a ce
que vous dites là aujourd'hui et ce que
nous on a entendu dans des audition
précédentes euh sur le fait que
finalement mise à part d'abord à terre
et puis un peu en île-de-fance l'élément
déclencheur de la mort de de Naël a été
finalement une motivation assez faible
et que en réalité on est on est très
vite tombé dans des émeutes qui
n'avaient pas de de de de sens ou de
revendication
politique qu'on pouvait identifier et
alors vous ne dites pas non plus qu
clairement he que c'est pas des des
revendications politiques identifiées
mais enfin vous vous avez une
analyse qui quand même montre bien que
même si ça n'est pas il y a pas de
revendication politique verbalisée il y
a pas d'organisation politique que il y
a quand même des sources très politiques
à à ces à ces émeutes finalement et que
et que donc on ne peut pas simplement
les résumer à une forme de niilisme ou à
à une
simple volonté d'en profiter pour piller
des magasins et et revendre et donc dans
une logique un peu consumériste que même
ça aussi c'est finalement c'est un acte
social et et donc aussi
euh politique et donc je j'aimerais euh
peut-être avoir un peu vos vos réactions
sur peut-être cette ces premières
analyses qu'on a qu'on a eu qui ont
tendance peut-être à à être omnibulé par
le niveau de la violence qui est
effectivement assez frappant euh et qui
qui nous a été euh décrit de manière
très saisissante par les policiers qu'on
a entendu les policiers les gendarmes
qu'on a entendu hier notamment et où eff
on a eu un niveau de violence beaucoup
plus élevé je crois que ce qu'on avait
pu voir auparavant euh mais
euh mais finalement aussi peut-être puis
qu'il y a eu de la violence dans les au
moment des gilets jaunes il y a eu de la
violence dans les manifestations dans
les outremèes quiil y avait eu
auparavant il y a eu de la violence un
peu dans les autour des des
manifestations retraite même si c'était
moindre ce qui veut dire que c'est une
viance qui est pas spécifique à ces
quartiers populaires euh que c'est
peut-être plus un contexte plus général
euh et euh et et donc quel est le
peut-être le
euh le le le l'interprétation politique
qu'on doit qu'on doit essayer de de
faire beaucoup plus fortement de ça
malgré le fait qu'il y a une forme de
euh enfin je qui donne l'impression
comme ça de Prim àord de de nilisme et
de et de simplement de consumérisme euh
qui n'a pas de signific enfin qui qui
qui qui peut être facilement balayé d'un
un peu trop facilement parfois balayé
d'un reververnementain merci Monsieur
Rogel
oui
euh vous
avez dit le mot il faudrait
déspécialiser
euh vous monsieur vous avez parlé du du
ghto qu'on était en train de fabriquer
en diminuant la mixité euh je me demande
si nos politiques publiques ne ne sont
pas allés euh à l'encontre finalement de
de l'objectif puisque la politique de la
ville conduit à spécialiser de plus en
plus les
quartiers je le le fait
que les maires n'ai pas la main sur le
peuplement fait que on peut pas agir
dans le sens de la mixité sociale moi
j'ai des quartiers qui se sont
ghettoisés
euh j'ai bien compris aussi que les
institutions sont pas les institutions
qui viennent des quartiers mais des des
institutions qu'on les médiathèques
qu'on jette dans les quartiers euh et
donc c'est pas les leurs
euh et quels sont les selon vous les les
incidences les les cons votre constat
conduit à un certain nombre de
conclusions institutionnelles qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait changer dans nos
politiques publiques pour arriver à un
résultat plus acceptable parce qu'on a
mis énormément d'argent on a refait ces
quartiers moi j'ai reconstruit des
quartiers entiers dans ma vie
et finalement ça n'a absolument pas
amélioré la
situation vous avez beaucoup parlé des
médiathèques mais aussi toutes les
cantines scolaaires les cantines
scolaires de leurs propres écoles qui
ont été
brûlées donc est-ce que vous pourriez à
partir du constat que vous avez
fait nous dire un peu ce qu'il faudrait
qu'on change pour que nos politiques
publiques soi arrivve à un résultat plus
efficace parce que à la limite les gens
disent c'est beaucoup d'argent jeté par
la fenêtre en fait voilà
bien vous avez une minute j'exagère
monsieur mercl peut-être ou monsieur
jardin puis signalez-vous hein pour
prendre la parole pas de problème
alors pour pour pour dire les choses de
manière très très
rapide on a on a parlé des des des
constats paradoxaux des des espèces de
contradictions qu'on qu'on observe ce
qui est clair c'est que dans tout ce qui
est de devant nous rien n'est univoque
je prends la question que
que rien ne va dans un sens clair et
donc pour reprendre la la question que
vous posiez d'une certaine façon comme
l'a dit François Dubet effectivement on
peut dire par par exemple si au lieu
d'avoir une mobilisation ou une réaction
des jeunes que c'est que que c'était-il
passé si c'était des mères des mamans on
a par exemple à Toulouse j'ai j'ai
beaucoup en enquêé sur une association
dans le quartier des zizards ce sont des
mamans qui se mobilisent pour défendre
les adolescents suite aux violences
liées au narcotraphique et cetera donc
qui protège la vie des adolescents on a
une protestation d'une autre nature bon
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec ces autres
acteurs qui ne prennent pas le devant de
la scène qui ne viennent pas sur le
devant de la scène pour
transformer la la la révolte en
revendication comme l'a dit François
Dubet mais de l'autre côté qu'est-ce que
nous avons eu le 27 juin l'image d'un
policier qui tue un jeune comm eu euh
avec son arme de service et ça c'est une
c'est un fait nouveau et donc il y a la
la on peut dire et et et nous serons
tous
d'accord la démocratie est malade mais
la maladie serait je dirais docteur
beaucoup plus grave si devant ces images
rien ne s'était passé et donc la le fait
qu'il y ait eu une révolte généralisée
montre une certaine santé de la
citoyenneté ce serait beaucoup plus
grave si nous étions dans des situations
comme par exemple connaissent le Brésil
ou le Mexique où la violence est
quotidienne la violence je dis des des
armes à feu d'un côté et de l'autre et
que il y avait une indifférence
généralisée c'était intégrée à la vie
démocratique la démocratie fonctionne
avec des morts euh dans la rue ou dans
les espaces de quartier populaire en
France ce n'est pas possible il y en a
un et la France s'enflamme et ça je
dirais tant mieux je je n'aimerais pas
j'aimerais qu'il n'y ait pas des écoles
des commissariats des des voilà prise
par cible mais il y a ce n'est pas clair
il faut y donner la clarté et ça c'est à
la parole politique de la construire
cette clarté de l'autre côté que se
passe-t-il avec les institutions il y a
une essence des institutions et en cela
je me distancie un petit peu je
comprends parfaitement bien ce que
François duvet dit autour du peuplement
et et c'est exact mais il y a une
présence institutionnelle cette présence
institution institutionnelle est à la
fois le salut et le problème on le voit
à travers l'école ceux qui s'en sortent
à l'école hop tant mieux mais ils s'en
vont et donc c'est c'est la bonne
intervention de la République de la répu
de la démocratie sociale mais en même
temps c'est la porte qui se ferme monée
de tout un tas de gens pour qui l'avenir
sera compromis parce qu'il maîtrise pas
la grand-mère et l'orthographe et donc
on dit à ces gens-là tu ne sais pas bien
écrire tu n'auras pas un travail digne
d'un avenir prometteur et donc on voit
bien que cette cette institution va
cristalliser euh une une une une
situation incroyable si le logement
social vous donne des logements de
qualité tout va bien et la la République
vous soutient mais si les ascenseurs
sont en panne la même institution qui
est la la solution à vos problèmes
devient la source des problèmes et la
même chose se passe aux urgences de
l'hôpital au contact avec la police et
cetera les institution de l'État social
dysfonctionnent parce que
elle dysfonctionne en interne dans leur
fonctionnement
interne mais aussi parce qu'elles n'ont
pas la capacité à répondre aux problèmes
sociaux l'école ne peut pas moduler le
marché du travail et donc qu' que le
muscle est perdu sa valeur dans le
marché du travail en France c'est une
question qui échappe à l'action des
instituteurs donc on peut pas demander
aux institutions de ressourre tous les
problèmes ce sont des situations
paradoxales qui ne trouveront pas de
solution facile et évidente sur le plan
local je veux dire quand les
bibliothécaires me demandent mais quoi
faire de mieux rien de mieux vous ne
pouvez pas mieux
faire malheureusement vous serez
confronté à un sit situation
conflictuelle la barque sera sécouée par
les vents qui traversent ces espaces
sociaux quoi que vous en fassiez ce
n'est pas un pessimisme c'est un constat
d'observateur disons c'est c'est
malheureux de dire ça à un élu c'est
malheureux de dire ça au directeur d'une
bibliothèque mais je ne pense pas qu'il
y
ait rien d'autre à faire que de
continuer à faire ce qui est
fait alors Monsieur jardin peut-être
quelques quelques points rapidement en
complément sur sur la question des
origines des émeutes et du niilisme ça a
été dit mais je crois que s'il y avait
pas eu les images il y aurait pas eu le
même impact et au-delà des image la
réaction politique au plus haut niveau
de l'État à finalement souligné l'enjeu
et l'importance de ce qui s'était passé
à
nenterre et les déclarations par la voix
de son avocat du mise en cause ont
confirmé le caractère intentionnel du
tir pas la caractère homicide mais
caractère intentionnel donc on éétait
pas dans une circonstance d'accident en
en cas d'espèce donc je pense que ça ça
a alimenté une conflictualité qui
n'aurait pas existé autrement et je
pense qu'on est convaincu que si on
avait pas eu ces images il n'y aurait
pas eu des protestation de cette
ampleur sur la question des trajectoires
des quartiers je pense que les
trajectoires sont très différentes selon
les quartiers il y a des territoires
marginalisés qui sont aux portes des
grandes métropoles qui elles connaissent
des dynamiques de gentrification et
d'ambourgeoisement parce qu' bénéficie
en fait d'un écosystème et d'un contexte
socio-économique qui permet le
développement l'arrivée des transports
en commun l'installation d'entreprise et
c'est ce qu'on voit notamment en scè
saint-oni qui est un territoire qui se
différencie très fortement et puis on a
des quartiers marginalisés de métropole
plus petites dans des régions plus
éloignées des grands pôles urbains où là
la marginalité est durable en l'absence
véritablement de perspectiv de
développement structurel de ces
territoire donc je pense qu'un des
enjeux essentiels c'est d'agir peut-être
sur ces territoires qui n'ont pas
d'autres ressources que euh l'action
publique pour bénéficier d'un
développement social et économique alors
que des territoires ont pu capter des
dynamiques liées lié à l'activité
économique générale je pense qu'un point
qui passe un peu sous silence c'est la
question de la démographie de ces
quartiers qui deviennent des quartiers
de plus en plus vieillissants euh qui
vont rester des quartiers plus jeunes
que le reste de la France mais dans
lesquels les enjeux euh du
vieillissement et de la transformation
de la structure des familles et des
générations sont sont très importants
euh et c'est quelque chose qui va sans
doute modifier leur rapport aux
politiques et leur rapport aux
institutions dans les années qui
viennent et peut-être un dernier point
sur quelque chose qui est souvent un peu
un impensé ou quelque chose qui est
pensé à part c'est le fait que il y a
des entrepreneurs moraux et identitaires
qui cherchent à formuler un discours
politique dans ces quartiers et ça passe
parfois par les structures qui sont liés
au courant islamiste ou rigoriste euh
qui tirent les bénéfices bah de cette
conflictualité avec les institutions et
qui tentent de dire nous nous avons la
capacité à générer les institutions
locales et euh petit travail que nous
avons fait avec mon collègue Hugo
Micheron euh sur les contenus en ligne
des organisations salafistes en France
euh elle parle beaucoup des émeutes elle
les condamne systématiquement elles en
parlent en termes sociaux et elles
s'intéressent aux conditions de vie dans
les quartiers donc il y a des dynamiques
qui sont vraiment des logiques
d'implantation idéologique et politique
euh qui s'inscrivent dans euh des
espaces interstitiels et dans des vides
euh pour ces populations parce que ben
elles ne sont plus immigrées
elles ne sont plus forcément ouvrières
ou pas dans le monde du
travail le quartier n'est pas quelque
chose qui produit tes propres ressources
d'identification le rapport à
l'ethnicité est pas un rapport légitime
en France pour se construire uneidentité
politique ben le religion est un support
disponible pour construire une identité
politique et ça se produit dans un
certain nombre de territoire pour une
certaine partie de la
population merci Monsieur jardin
peut-être du côté de Monsieur Domingo
monsieur
dub
allez-y allez-y monsieuring je relance
mon micro
bonjour beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites moi je pense ce que soulignit
Monsieur dub sur les contradictions
finalement de l'action publique ça me
paraît au cœur de d'un certain nombre de
nos difficultés c'estàd des injonctions
contradictoires et une parole politique
qui pèse on a dans un écosystème
médiatique qui est qui est lui-même
conflictuel où on parle des quartiers
euh ou des populations des quartiers
sans qu'en effet que que les les
premiers concernés soient à soit relayé
donc on a vu aussi pendant ces émeutes
des habitants qui se sont mobilisés pour
sauver leurs écoles donc euh euh vous
parliez tout à l'heure un de mes
collègues parlent de l'expérience euh de
maman qui essaie de construire des
choses donc je pense qu'il il y a des
enjeux où il faut reconstruire du
politique par le bas hein euh retisser
du lien social et pas seulement penser
dans un sur le plan purement
urbanistique ou dur euh il faut retisser
des formes de lien social les réinventer
peut-être parce qu'elles se sont
peut-être dstructuré au fil des ans donc
là il y a il y a un enjeu par le bas qui
implique d'ailleurs très directement à
mon avis les collectivités locales leur
capacité avec l'État à à avoir
une une logique qui aille dans le même
sens et sans contradiction et puis il y
a peut-être aussi un volet plus plus
sociétal plus méta hein sur la parole
publique sur la manière dont on parle de
ces quartier dont on identifie les
populations dont on en parle parce que
je pense qu'elles sont aussi réceptives
à à à cette forme de
décrochage qui fait qu'ensuite ça a été
aussi dit il y a des formes alternatives
au-delà de l' meutes qui vont permettre
de de construire du politique du
politique sans plus ordinaire mais
beaucoup plus concret et qui permet de
de vivre au jour le jour et donc le le
religieux est un de ses leviers mais
aussi la marginalisation hein parfois
est une de ses conséquences euh
c'est-à-dire on ne parle le plus il y a
pas d' meut là aussi c'est problématique
hein parce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
sûrement des gens qui s'enfment qui
s'enferment dans dans dans des processus
de très grande pauvreté et avec une
incapacité à se mobiliser même même par
le biais de la violence donc je pense
qu'on a un effet un problème de modèle
et qui qui est en tension parce qu'en
plus on est sur la une province
républicaine celle de l'école mais plus
largement une province républicaine qui
est très forte en France et dont les
populations et notamment les populations
jeunes voi bien que cette promesse a des
difficultés à se mettre concrètement en
œuvre et donc là on est dans une vraie
tension
euh une tension où l'État finalement
fait beaucoup de choses en France mais
cette action elle est mal perçue et il y
a une forme de désajustement très fort
entre ce que font les autorités publiqu
et et la manière dont dont cette action
est est perçue est appropriée dans dans
ces quartiers donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'on AR et c'est c'est là où on rejoue
l'enjeu démocratique c'est comment on
sort d'une de dispositif pour recréer
des formes de démocratie plus ordinaires
dans le cadre de C de cette politique de
la ville alors peut-être avec moins
parfois d'argent mais avec des une
reconstruction d'un lien social qui
aujourd'hui est à la peine et qui est
lié à tous les processus qui on qui ont
pu être exposé
précédemment merci Monsieur Domingo je
sais pas si Monsieur Dubet veut prendre
la parole non je très très rapidement je
je je pardonnez-moi oui très très
rapidement je voudrais rappeler que il
faut il faut admettre à la fois que ce
sont des révoltes et que ce sont des
émeutes et que dans lesmeut on en
connaît depuis très longtemps dans les
émeutes il y a il y a il y a il y a des
rationalités qui sont euh strictement
délinquante ludique le bonheur de
détruire et et ça ne date pas d'hier je
veux dire on a toute une histoire des
émeutes qui montrre que c'était pas très
sympathique mais il n'empêche que le
cœur c'est celui d'une injustice d'une
révolte et cetera donc euh je crois que
c'est on est on est confronté à ça et et
peut-être au-delà aujourd'hui de des
banlieux après tout euh j'été très
frappé de voir comment le mouvement des
gilets jaunes a été a eu de grandes
difficultés à produire une revendication
C des gens très en colère mais euh qui
avait beaucoup de mal à produire une une
demande une demandeon donc c'est c'est
un mécanisme assez général ce qui nous
pourrait créer d'ailleurs chez beaucoup
d'entre nous la nostalgie des syndicats
des mouvements d'éducation populaire de
toutes ces machines à refroidir les
colères que nous avons peut-être trop
mal traité bon je voudrais le dire au
passage moi je je crois que le
remplacement des mouvements d'éducation
populaire par des prestataires de
service c'est pas une c'est pas
forcément une bonne chose c'est même pas
une bonne chose du tout donc je je je
crois que on est quand même devant ce
problème euh alors il n'est pas que
français mais nous sommes
particulièrement forts là-dessus parce
que nous sommes centralisateurs et
cetera et cetera donc je crois qu'il
faut bien comprendre là-dessus euh la
deuxième chose ça a été dit et nous
sommes tous embarrassé là-dessus c'est
que si on veut que les acteurs de ces
quartiers
deviennent les habitants de ces
quartiers deviennent des acteurs il
fautra bien admettre au jour qu'il
deviennent des acteurs des acteurs en
étant ce qu'ils sont or il et c'est
notre tout notre problème avec l'islam
après tout c'est à la fois c'est à la
fois des choses extrêmement dangere
heureuse et c'est à la fois la seule
chose qui fait qui fabrique du lien de
la dignité euh et donc je je suis moi
comme tout tout Français normalement
constitué très embarrassé mais on peut
pas dire au 19e siècle ou breton soyez
sympa organisez-vous mais sans
catholicisme bon les Bretons étaient
catholiques voilà et donc il y a quelque
chose de de cet ordre là qui qui n'est
pas réglé et de ce point de vue-là le
discours médiatique de stigmatisation
est tout à fait fait terrifiant et je
voudrais bien préciser que je n'ai
aucune naïveté par
rapport à certaine forme d'islamisme
ensuite je crois qu'on peut agir quand
même sur le peuplement on a peut-être un
peu renoncé rapidement à essayer de
créer un peu de mixité dans les
quartiers et je voudrais dire c'est le
dernier point que on pourrait agir
beaucoup mieux qu'on ne le fait sur la
mixité scolaire je veux dire que on
puisqueon a un toulousain parmi nous il
y a eu un exemple célèbre à Toulouse où
on a tout cassé un collège ultra
ghettoïé ça a pris beaucoup de temps
pour convaincre les collèges de classe
moyenne d'à côté qu'avoir quelques
Arabes chez eux ça serait pas une
catastrophe mais ça a marché donc on
peut le faire et je crois que de ce
côté-là aussi si on faisait confiance
aux acteurs locaux on s'en tierait
parfois un peu mieux que nous ne le
faisons après tout les pays plus
décentralisés que le nôtre sentir pas
plus mal sur toutes ces
questions-là merci Monsieur mais
vraiment c'est passionnant tout ce que
vous nous avez dit alors moi je partage
beaucoup de choses et je pense qu'il y a
pas une solution facile mais la question
du peuplement je pense que c'est une
question fondamentale et elle répond
parfaitement à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'està-dire que la gettoisation
elle tient aussi beaucoup au au mécanism
même qu'on a mis en place aux règles
qu'on s'est infligé pour des tas de
raisons euh positiv ou pas positive mais
qui ont fait que les maires enfin les
élus locaux pour faire plus simple se
sont retrouvés bloqués dans des
situations quis auraient sans doute géré
différemment al sans excès on est bien
d'accord différemment et mais en tous
les cas de manière plus équilibrée je
pas raconter ma vie d'élu j'ai été mère
pendant 20 ans d'une commune du Rône euh
avec des quartiers c un petit territoire
mais dense 27000 habitants avec des des
quartiers compliqué on a réussi à gérer
tout ça correctement mais avec avec
cette forme équilibre qu'on a
réintroduit dans certains secteurs dans
d'autres on n' pas hésité à démolir et
ça va être en cours de reconstruction je
vous cache pas que le mon inquiétude sur
la reconstruction est grande parce qu'on
est encore sur les mécanismes anciens en
terme de réflexion et que si on y prend
pas garde ce que l'on va faire ou ce qui
pourrait être fait dans les années qui
viennent va générer dans quelques années
la même situation que nous avons
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est toujours sur
ce même modèle et il faut arriver je
pense impérativement en sortir et puis
je termine par le un petit moment de
gloire de ma vie communale j'avais dans
un quartier une école primaire qui était
dans une situation de gettoisation mais
totale absolument total et j'avais
obligé je le dis vraiment obligé après
une grosse colère d'ailleurs l'éducation
nationale de dire on rase l'école et on
réaffecte les enfants en dehors d'école
maternelle dans les autres quartiers de
dans les autres écoles des autres
quartiers de la ville avec un système
qu'on av appelé buzing parce que le bus
les prenait enfin trs et ça continue
toujours d'ailleurs parce que le
quartier n'est pas encore construit et
bien je ne regrette pas du tout une
seule seconde de l'avoir fait parce que
finalement tous les directeurs des
autres écoles y compris les enfants tout
ça s'est passé merveilleusement bien
avec des résultats scolaires de grande
qualité et on a probablement aidé des
gamins à à faire des choses qu'il
n'auraient pas faites si on avait pas
fait ça et alors c'est un peu
particulier parce que mon territoire est
pas très grand on peut le faire mais le
principe en tous les cas est pour moi un
principe qui mérite d'être multiplier
lorsque les situations deviennent
inextricable sinon on n sortira pas bon
tout ça c'est une petite réflexion avant
le déjeuner parce que je vous ai écouté
et que ça m'a rappelé quelques souvenirs
mais la complexité que vous avez évoqué
est quand même tout à fait fondamental
et si on se pose pas les bonnes
questions je suis pas sûr qu'on trouve
les bonnes solutions l'enjeu c'est de
réussir à trouver des canaux de
désaccords et d'affrontement politique
qui ne passe pas par la violence voici
la conclusion de cette série d'audition
qui a pour but de déterminer les causes
et les origine profonde des violences
urbaines qui ont suivi la mort du jeune
Naël l'été dernier la commission
d'enquête du Sénat poursuit désormais
ses travaux quant à moi je vous souhaite
une très belle journée sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires